good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me i'm
lawrence jones and what a difference
a year makes tomorrow marks the one-year
anniversary of the death of george floyd
in the weeks and months that followed
american companies did their best to
prove
how woke and committed they were to
promoting diversity and social justice
corporations were promising money left
and right after george ford's
death 50 billion dollars in fact was
pledged to advance in racial equity
in this country that's billion with the
b
some of it was supposed to be donated to
civil rights organizations
invested in communities of color or put
toward reimagining hiring practices
at major corporations and now a year
later
how much do you think was actually spit
take a minute and guess 80 percent how
about 50
25 what if i told you that only half of
one percent
250 million dollars was actually spent
by these companies
in support of black life i bet you think
their
holier-than-thou pledges of generosity
was a bunch of bull
that they were hollow virtual signal and
that black communities and organizations
were never going to get the support they
were promised well you'd
be exactly right the one group that did
manage to get a whole boatload of cash
was
black lives matter they pulled in more
than 90 million dollars last year
but only managed to spend a quarter of
it on charitable causes
the group's been so shady with the money
that tamir's rights mom
begged the group to stop profiting off
her son's death
that probably explains why according to
the new york times look at this
public support of black lives matter has
cratered since june
20. what a difference a year
makes joining me now to discuss is maz
torre
founder of black guns matter maj uh you
always tell it like it
is so why is the support dropping
the support is dropping because the
people are following the money
a bunch of the money darren seals told
us before he was murdered
black lives matter incorporated as a
sham organization
designed specifically to fleece the
black community
has nothing to do with improving the
conditions of black america
and nato ops period so maj
uh so you got the organization then you
got the people that are on the street
that have sincere calls for justice but
then you have the organization
they got all the dough making all these
promises because they
were pressured to do so but when it came
down to the nitty-gritty
the community didn't see a lot of that
doe so the question is will there be
boycotts
for these corporations or will there be
pressure
to pay up because i want to see the doe
yeah
i i don't i don't want the boycott the
black community want the money
y'all said that money was supposed to be
for our community
you said it you you plastered these the
black lives matter
let me go back a second yes we know that
black lives matter
as a reality obviously right and some
people in america wanted to pretend like
that wasn't the case so i want to make
that clear distinction
between the people doing legitimate work
community work
and the incorporation that funneled
this was a money laundering scheme if i
as black guns matter
we raised and gave away over the last
four years we do work in firearms safety
and suicide prevention and conflict
resolution in black communities for the
last four years
we've raised four hundred and ten
thousand dollars give or take
and i've been very transparent with the
money can you imagine
if i'm at conservative tables can you
imagine with
how they would have crucified me if i
only spent a quarter of that four
hundred thousand dollars a quarter
25 percent of it on this stated purpose
no it was a money laundering scheme
and a whole bunch of that money don't
want to get anybody in trouble but yes i
do
a whole bunch of that money was funneled
to the democratic party and joe biden
and his team's whole scenario that's
where the money at
follow the paper that's why the the
plummet has happened
amongst the black community you see it
so you got that aspect
then you have the other aspect of them
saying look we're going to hire
more black folks in those communities
we're going to put more job businesses
there do the work you know not just
crops we're going to put
big business in these communities and
we're going to make sure that we're
going to hire black people
that didn't happen either this from the
same group of people
that paid to destroy the businesses in
them same communities
my community they bust in a gang of
people that wasn't from there
incorporated not the people that lived
there we've seen scores of people over
the last year
stopping people from doing things in
communities saying hey you don't live
here
we hear about a peaceful assembly we're
here about a peaceful protest
people getting bust in with a lot of
money that came from somewhere
to destroy those businesses in the first
place this is the let me create the
problem
let me present a solution so you look
run to me as your savior
black lives matter incorporated not the
people not the rank and file black
community
that's doing the work black lives matter
incorporated is a money
laundering scheme and they better get
that bread right
so um here's the rub
we know this the community
knows this the community has been going
after black lives matter for a while
they say we're small but we're not
supporting the organization we just want
equal justice under the law so the
community knows this
they've been pushing back against that
you can name name after name brianna
taylor's family tamira's rice family
they have been very vocal about this so
the question
is who's giving the money
to these groups are they white liberal
coming because black america is already
having the conversation
so who's trying to feel good
the honorable el hajj malik el shabazz
malcolm x said
the white liberal is the most dangerous
thing
to the black american ever white
liberals
are behind and funding this anti-family
anti-nuclear family unit anti-strong
father in the household
movement that has been morphed into
something that has been very detrimental
for our community if you want to tell me
that
you know hey we're going to be helping
you but we have to control all of the
money
we got to funnel it through act blue i
question you
the money will make a man change gods
and if we keep following that money
we're gonna see all of the white
liberals
and and a sprinkling of some of the
black folks that bought million-dollar
homes
off some of that bread yeah right we're
gonna see that but
nah the liberals is running that and
that ain't for the hood no more we got
our own work to do you want to support
something
support black guns matter we actually do
what we say we're gonna do with the
money
yeah we're gonna keep following this
because i like following the money i
like looking at the receipts
and seeing who paid up and marge i know
you do too so
i'm so glad that you joined the program
today hopefully you'll come back again
thanks brother hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else